bien j'ai envie de vous faire partager
comment j'ai transformé une étape de vie
difficiles en construction positive et
je crois que pour ça je fais de voir un
petit peu me dénuder mon impossible à
moi c'était plutôt un à penser dans
l'ordre de ces choses qui ne nous ont
jamais traversé l'esprit qu'ils ne sont
même jamais venu rencontrer nos pensées
j'avais à peine la quarantaine
j'étais directrice commerciale en pleine
ascension professionnelle ambitieuse et
très engagée dans mon métier
mes trois enfants n'étaient plus en bas
âge et je pouvais pleinement m'investir
dans ma vie de femme active
j'avais trouvé un bon équilibre entre
une vie professionnelle qui me
permettait de m'épanouir
intellectuellement et une vie privée qui
me permettait de profiter de mes enfants
avec lesquels j'avais passé du temps par
exemple l'éducation sportive s'était
aussi en famille de même que les
découvertes culturelles visites de
musées séjour à l'étranger
concert événement urbain et puis au fil
du temps notre as notre atmosphère
familiale s'est transformée comme ça
arrive parfois et un moment donné à la
maison c'était le chaos séparation
d'avec le père de mes enfants maladie et
surtout des rives de ma fille aînée
alors adolescente en deux trimestres
elle était passée d'élèves brillante et
exemplaire à élèves perturbatrice
insolente est totalement désengagé de
l'école
un ensemble de tourments qui ce qui
s'invitait qui s'invitait à moi en même
temps mais je ne laissait rien paraître
dans ma vie de manager la cloison entre
la journée au travail et la soirée en
famille était totalement étanche jusque
là tout va bien
à peu près et puis un matin le stop
licenciement alors pour moi qui faisait
bouillir la marmite dans un rythme de
vie totalement effréné c'était un vrai
choc
jusque là j'avais une carrière
ascensionnelle et jeunes avaient changé
que par libre choix au moment où cette
situation se présente je suis au bord du
burn out
au moment où ces sept années de
boutiques vont s'achever en 13 minutes
exactement
c'est court 13 minutes
je reprends mon souffle mais à peine
finalement une injonction du lycée me
parvient madame nous avons signalé votre
fille au numéro vert numéro stop
djihadisme
elle dit vouloir partir en egypte dans
trois jours appelez-le et ils vous
indiqueront la marche à suivre
forte heureusement j'étais assise quand
cet appel m'est arrivé alors bien sûr je
savais ma fille convertie à l'islam
c'était une de mes préoccupations
majeures non pas parce qu'elles étaient
convertis mais parce que elle avait mis
au centre de ses intérêts cette religion
au détriment de tout le reste mais stop
djihadisme ce tourbillon de tourments
très important était arrivé comme je
vous l'expliquais dans la même période
temps et parallèlement il se trouve que
je vivais une reconstruction amoureuse
tout en bonheur
c'est curieux parfois comme le pire et
le meilleur vient de se côtoyer dans le
même espace temps pour parler de ma
fille elle se désintéresse de tous ceux
qui la lie à l'éducation qu'elle a reçue
et coll enfin je veux dire réussite
scolaire loisirs sports dessin musique
vêtements elle se transforme tout y
passe
telle une wonder woman elle se
revendique d'un islam pur et authentique
elle change de prénom
nous l'avons choisie avec soin ce prénom
il est merveilleux ce prénom inscrit son
extrait d'acte de naissance
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe plus
je la tire à moi plus elle s'éloigne
plus je tempère ma fille tu as le temps
pour les grands choix de vie plus elle
s'empresse je dois épouser ce garçon
pour pouvoir le fréquenter plus je
m'oppose parce que le quotidien devient
invivable avec les repas qui doivent
être ceux ci la musique qui est pêché la
bise aux hommes qui n'est plus admis ns
plus le groupe qui l'entourent la tire
ta mère est une égarés elle ne te
comprends pas et c'est normal
elle redouble d'énergie pour tonifier
ses connaissances dit religieuse me
voici petit pot de terre contre pot de
fer
et je ferraille dur pour la maintenir
dans notre mode de vie familiale et pour
éviter la rupture scolaire puis impact
de la reconstruction amoureuse tout en
bonheur je suis enceinte quatrième
enfant ou plutôt quatrième grossesse et
vous savez comme pour une femme la
période de maternité n'est pas propice
au repositionnement professionnel
surtout avec mon logiciel de l'époque
qui se nomme faire carrière
alors je décide de mettre à profit cette
parenthèse j'écris je me lance dans
quelque chose de vertigineux pour
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais écrit deere
témoigné tendre la main tendre la main à
d'autres parce qu'ils sont nombreux les
autres je les ai rencontrés ces autres
parents qui me ressemble seulement moi
je suis debout j'ai du temps neuf mois
chez l'être humain
une plume il envie d'écrire l'envi de
mettre en mots je décide que j'accouche
raid à bord d'un manuscrit ce que je
fais et je l'envoie comme une bouteille
d'eau à la mer en me disant au pire joe
taux est dit très et je diffuserai mon
récit par le biais des associations de
parents que je côtoie
à la suite de cela à nouveau vont se
côtoyer immense joie et profonde
détresse elle est tout juste majeur ma
fille à cette période là et un matin
elle 120 comme l aurait fait l'école
buissonnière finalement pour traverser
la manche et rejoindre un prince
charmant inconnu
nous sommes terrassé pour ce noël nous
avons à nouveau né un petit garçon
merveilleux qui nous émerveille en tout
cas et il ne plaît béante avec l'absence
de sa plus grande soeur passer les fêtes
un coup de fil je veux vous éditez
explosion de joie pour moi qui avais
passé des heures à écrire un éditeur
belge qui vient à moi il est militant je
précise belge parce que à cette période
là nos amis voisins sont déjà très très
sensible à s'être à 7 à ce sujet d'un
autre islam qui veut repenser le mal la
manière de vivre ensemble
je réunis mes enfants nous vivons des
moments difficiles en famille mais de
cette épreuve mais une construction
positive
un livre il est là bientôt dans les bacs
il sent bon le papier j'en suis fier
a radio télé presse j'ai la chance
d'intéresser quelques médias avec mes
180 pages et puis un titre d'article
mère patience ça beaucoup amuser mes
enfants mr patience alors justement j'ai
envie de vous parler de ce courage et de
cette patience qu'on me loue maintenant
imaginez votre fille se cache sous un
grand voile noir dissimule jusqu'à ses
yeux décide de partir en angleterre
vivre sa vie de deuxième épouse
vous décidez d'en témoigner parce qu'il
vous semble que le propos dépasse
largement le cas de votre fille
et là j'entends âme et moi avec mon
autorité une bonne éducation n'aurait
pas pu m'arriver
ou alors prenons ça moi chez moi ça va
pas pu arriver dans ma famille ou bien
encore la messe ce sont des mômes à
problèmes pour se lancer dans de telles
absurdités
ah oui parce que vous pensez qu'il n'y a
pas de logique derrière ces morceaux de
carrière fanatiques
je ne sais pas ça fait beaucoup
d'enfants tout de même qu'ils quittent
qui partent et qui croit alors
évidemment penser qu'ils sont devenus
fous c'est plus simple
à partir de là moi j'ai eu envie de
comprendre de savoir de décortiquer de
faire la part des choses
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
d'interprétation en islam
alors j'ai lu lu encore écouté pris des
notes tenter des schémas pour
conceptualiser ma compréhension de cette
situation et puis des hommes et des
femmes issus du même courant religieux
sont venus à moi et ils m'ont expliqué
comment c'était quand il était dedans
à quel point il avait souffert quel
avait été leur privation ce qui leur
avait donné envie d'en sortir
et puis comment il s'était reconstruit
sans ce squelette idéologique
bref vous l'avez compris le sujet m'a
saisit aux tripes mais s'est emparé de
ménage alors je tire trois leçons de
cette situation
la première c'est sans doute l'humilité
en tant que parent je ne peux pas tout
bien sûr dans l'idée mon enfant suivra
le chemin qu'il souhaitera mais dans la
réalité l'enfant idéal la petite fille
idéale la petite soeur et des alpes
reste perché dans l'esprit et quand
l'enfant en réel se présente ce peut
être la chute parce que non ce n'est pas
facile à accepter l'enfant réel qui se
moquent bien d'avoir un métier qui
l'épanouissent ou même plus simplement
un métier qui lui permette de subvenir à
ses besoins ou encore un enfant qui
rejette tout ce qui constitue votre
bien-être
qui se donne une ligne de vie et des
croyances totalement aux antipodes des
vôtres deuxième leçon la bienveillance
après tout chacun son chemin
ce n'est pas une fin en soi de faire ce
chemin ce choix de vie à 18 ans la route
est longue
je ne vais tout de même pas cessé
d'aimer mon enfant parce qu'ils se
retrouvent dans un dispositif totalement
différent de mon idéal de vie je ne vais
pas lui tourner le dos parce qu'ils
décident de vivre sa vie des pousses
vieux en angleterre
autre leçon que j'ai prise tout
dernièrement c'est à propos de ce que
sont les petits bonheurs
vous savez il est fréquent dans le temps
dit il faut savoir profiter de ce qui se
présente ici et maintenant je l'ait
vraiment compris tout simplement parce
qu'à 45 ans je suis grand mère alors
connaître l'orthographe exacte du prénom
de ma petite fille c'est un petit
bonheur admirait son petit visage rond
sur une photo qui me parvient un peu par
hasard une chance je me réjouis parce
que je vois qu'elle va bien et je suis
sûr qu'un jour je le tiendrai la main
comme vous pouvez le comprendre cette
expérience personnelle m'a intimement
transformé ma petite charlotte saisie
d'une quête spirituelle à 12 ans est
embarqué dans un communautarisme de
rupture à 18 ans et probablement
l'illustration d'un autre fait de
société
depuis 2014
beaucoup de jeunes sont partis tous
séduits par diverses sirène qui chacune
chante la vérité
l'état se mobilise prend des mesures on
cherche des recettes pour la
déradicalisation les préfectures
activent leurs réseaux mobilisent leur
vigilance pour éviter les risques de
basculement des experts des chercheurs
des artistes beaucoup se mobilisent sur
ce sujet et la radicalisation comme un
arbre qui cache la forêt car derrière
ces mouvements extrêmes c'est notre
harmonie de vie qui est menacée des
familles sont totalement déchiré et des
enfants sont élevés dans l'obscurantisme
et le rejet de l'autre parce qu'il pense
différemment parce qu'il est différent
alors cette ce croisement d'expériences
personnelles et de réalités sociales
fortes m'a conduit à repenser mon propre
positionnement en tant que femme active
contributeurs de la société et j'ai
trouvé ma place c'est celle d'être
acteurs de la prévention pour dire
expliqué mettre en mots continuer à
chercher
ainsi je peux dire que quelque chose
d'un pensée est devenu possible
le parcours de ma fille et que d'une
situation personnelle particulièrement
douloureuse j'ai transformé en
construction positive et comme je ne
sais pas de quoi sera fait demain je ne
présage surtout pas de ce que sera la
suite